i still live in media you ever think you  were depressed but you just really  needed a haircut  [Applause]  and you got a haircut like what was i  worried about i'm fresh as [ __ ]  i'm super fresh everything's fine i'm  all good i'm never gonna die  i'm gonna live forever i'm immortal how  can somebody so fresh ever die  i'm gonna every everything's all right  my  nights you ever think you would a  haircut but you just really were  depressed  i'm super haircut fresh everything's  depressed i'm gonna die  everything's all right my  nights what was i worried about i'm  depressed  i'm super depressed everything's haircut  haircut  haircut regular haircut woman who cut my  hair  had a mask and gloves on my  knife everything's fine i'm super  depressed small  hair fresh is fine i'm all good i'm  dying  everything's alright